joining us now here on the rich eisen
show is a fellow
nominee for best studio host uh for the
sports emmy awards but she is the only
one
in this group of nominees with hair the
host
of the jump on espn the emmy nominated
host rachel nichols here on the rich
island show how are you rachel
hello mr eisen how are you i am doing
very well i'm doing i i guess i'm
i'm doing better than the celtics
organization i think
right now well you're probably having a
less surprised morning how about that
well so but this had to be in the works
right i mean
as as we're going through the throws of
the season
um are you surprised by
the uh the maneuvers in the front office
and brad stevens last night strolling
off barkley center
having coached his last game it appears
for the for the celtics
yeah i mean look i spoke to danny ainge
just this friday
and it's funny because sometimes right
before a game and that's when i saw him
on the court
you know he can be kind of focused on
the game right you know athletes pregame
always an athlete once an athlete
and just started tense and he was chatty
and friendly and
and forthcoming and and even though at
that point the celtics were already
down in the series and it was a more
relaxed danny age than i expected now in
hindsight does that mean
something that he already knew what this
was going on
probably i can't say for sure but we did
talk about the future of the team and he
said that he thought the team was in
really good shape
with a core of two all-stars under the
age of 25
and i asked him about brad stevens who
has obviously taken some criticism in
the boston market this season
and he said ah and he's like there's
nothing that you would ever blame brad
for and he said
as far as i'm concerned brad could be
with this organization as long as he
wants
and uh i guess that is true just in a
very different way than we expected
in his job i mean that's so did you get
any sense at all
now in retrospect um uh a sort of spidey
sense in a way
talking to to ange that something
was coming or do you think this was
actually something that happened this
morning
no i certainly didn't and i can say that
people within the celtics organization
who work with him every day uh didn't
have that feeling there was a lot of
people in that organization
texts flying around this morning saying
you know just sort of wow or
i can't believe this is happening but uh
you know i'm sure people close to him
knew
and uh you know danny age pulled off one
last thing people didn't expect
so what do you think who do you think um
i mean i guess this is a first blush
isn't the proper word for it but
um all options clearly will be on the
table who wants to coach jason tatum
jaylen brown and
uh with all those banners hanging over
your head
i imagine that there'll be a line out
the door what do you think
yeah i mean i i think there's there's
candidates but i'd want to take a minute
before i start speculating because then
that speculation sometimes becomes news
um but but i will say that it's a job
that has of course an enormous spotlight
on it and it will probably require
someone who is
experienced and tough and able to handle
all of the
things that come with being the head of
the boston celtics on the court it comes
with
a tremendous amount of responsibility an
enthusiastic and rabid fan base which is
what you want
right i mean that's what some cities and
teams would kill to have
and um a legacy and and resources in
that organization that that are so
strong i mean obviously of all those
former players to lean on
um ownership in that city is really
strong in the nba
but also an enormous amount of pressure
you know that boston is a city that now
is so different from when i was growing
up but now expects titles in every sport
and um certainly with as danny pointed
out to me just a few days ago
you know those two young players jaylen
brown and jason tatum
uh who are the strongest sort of
backbone of a team
that you could kind of ask for at that
age who do you fill in around them and
how do you win with them
and uh when is kyrie's first media
availability
um rachel what is that when does that
happen is
i'm sure we will see kyrie again after
game one
of the boston i'm sorry of the brooklyn
yes
uh milwaukee series which is saturday
night so who's going to ask him the
question
will it
be the team that that ends the the
celtics season as well as their
long time running construct uh in the
front office and on
on the bench i will say this i i
obviously i i don't danny's talking
right now i believe i don't know all of
all of the motors behind his thinking
but i can't imagine
this decision was made having to do
anything with how this series went
this is such a difficult year for boston
they fell so far below
their own expectations in terms of where
they wanted to be it's a team that was
in the eastern conference finals three
of the previous four years
and this season they found themselves
scraping just for a playoff spot
and i think that you know some of that's
coved they had
you know a couple really bad bouts of it
go through the team you heard jason
tatum and then evan fournier talk about
how they had lasting effects jason
couldn't breathe for a long time even
after he was back playing had to start
using an inhaler just to
play games evan fournier talked about
even once he was back he felt like he
was
uh in a fog and had a concussion all of
the time he had headaches and i don't
think they've completely gone away
um so i think they've just had some bad
luck with all of that stuff they had
injuries and it was just a difficult
season all of the teams that were in the
bubble toward the end last year
have sort of you know had some tough
things to deal with um
i don't get the impression that anyone
walked into this series with the
brooklyn nest this first round thinking
oh yeah we're going to win this
so i don't think the way it ended is
having any long-term
effect on anyone's future i think it's
just sort of the end
quota to a difficult year that probably
you know these decisions
came over time or difficult two years
that kind of started with kyrie smudging
boston garden let's uh let's
also go back to that right with them
walking around with incense around the
perimeter of the court
i'm trying to stir something up for you
rachel you're doing something today the
stage you want the stage do you think
that that we need to like have the sage
we're doing the emmys virtually right
yes so
i think we'll be on some giant zoom type
things yes
i've already gotten many of the emails
about how hardwired the computer needs
to be
so but i i i i'll share with you what i
responded to the
you know to the emmys when they wanted
me to hardwire my computer at home and
you know um it's how impossible that
concept would possibly be i've got a
laptop i said i can shoot a video of
myself
reacting to ernie johnson winning and
you can play that instead is what i sent
back
so i think you know well good that'll be
your video
my video will have a little sage in it
and we can clap for ernie
phil jackson did it first so if you're
gonna if you're going to talk to kyrie
about that you got to talk to kill
jackson first
so a 12th ring is going to come from
this essentially potentially apparently
with the nets moving forward i've got
rachel nichols here on the rich eyes and
show a few more minutes left with the
host of the jump on espn and so much
more
um so let's get into the injuries out
west
um with um you know obviously
a significant injury that it seemed like
um chris paul has finally suffered last
night
and then the lakers getting blown out
with um
charles barkley referred to him as
street clothes on tnt last night
yes in anthony davis um how significant
are these injuries do you think moving
forward even for whoever does
emerge from this uh battle of attrition
between the two and seven here
i think they're significant uh i i think
it sounded like for money williams post
game press conference last night that
chris paul
you know is not as injured as he was the
first time i don't i guess that's
that's what we that's what we consider
good news these days in the nba right
now sports um you know the the anthony
davis injury
feels significant only in that you know
he was out for a big chunk of this
season with sort of an achilles spy
kind of injury and then he injured his
knee in the first round of the playoffs
and now it's his groin and it's all on
the same
side of his body so you've got knee
thigh groin basically on the same side
that's that you know i'm not a doctor as
they say but
it's it's not hard to say that you start
getting these compensation injuries and
that one
one part of your body is a little bit
weaker because it's trying to have extra
support for another part of your body
especially if it's on the same all on
the same leg so
um i don't know if he's going to be able
to come back for game six certainly uh
the lakers need him to
but i do know that they have to be
concerned that if they bring him back
you know and they win and they then win
a game seven you know is he gonna turn
is he gonna hurt something else or is it
gonna be a long term more long-term
injury
and there's just no way for us to know
that we've got to see what anthony
decides with the medical team there's
luca's neck there's
there's joelle's knee i mean my gosh the
the big stars are i i guess you know
bubble wrap giannis
uh all three nets right donovan mitchell
that's what's funny i mean who spent the
most of the season
with one injury or another to the point
where i believe they only played like
seven or eight games together by the
time we got to the right
end of the regular season was the three
brooklyn nets and then look who are the
three guys who are healthy right now
and then there was last night's game
that was um on nba tv uh
my gosh i i i mean i led the show with
you know damian lillard he's he is up
there with steph
in terms of or any player mahomes in the
nfl
name anybody who gets you off the couch
with their play i mean he is
he is he's for first straight his hall
of fame first rate
he's i can't get and then the blazers
lose
when it comes down to it as well the
great nuggets performance that
that um obviously i'm sweeping under the
rug but i i'll just give you the floor
on
on lillard and and what you think about
him and what you've learned about him
and covering him for as long as you have
rachel he's so fascinating right i mean
this is a guy who's been undersized
ever since he picked up a basketball uh
you know went to a college that i think
a lot of people have only heard of
because of him
um and certainly not someone tabbed to
be
one of the best players in the nba and
none of that has ever
mattered to him and that's easy to say
right you know we got a lot of young
guys with chips on their shoulders
saying yeah i always believed in myself
yeah i knew and i used the haters for
fuel but
it's a lot easier to put on that front
and that bravado than to actually
believe it and do it and have that faith
in yourself and your core
that even when the world is telling you
over and over again this just isn't for
you
um being able to say yeah i actually
know it is and i know better
um and i know what i can do and i know
what i can become and i've always been
fascinated that dame has had that in him
in such a
certain way um and then you know his
just
absolute belief that there's no excuses
and that you know whatever he has around
him is what he has and wherever he goes
is what he does and we saw that last
night
i mean the amount of quote support he
got on that court was
it's not what anyone in portland's
locker room would want i mean the shot
chart
of everyone except damien lillard in the
two overtimes on the portland side
it's embarrassing and the fact that he
just kept
shooting and kept going through all of
that and then you also have to credit
um the nuggets i mean i know you said no
disrespect to them but i mean this is a
team that lost its second best player
and only one really after that and has
kept its nose in the series and now
leads it which is an incredible story
on that side i do wonder though do you
think that damien lillard
is the most liked person in the nba is
there another
big star that you can say
has only positive vibes around him in
terms of the public in terms of fellow
players
who dislikes his teammate okay let me
ask you who who dislikes steph curry
like what human being
dislikes steph curry i couldn't agree
with you more rich
possible to dislike steph curry but go
on the internet there's a whole section
of steph curry haters to the point where
it's become part of his kind of public
persona that he doesn't pay attention to
them
um i don't understand how you can watch
steph curry with anything
except wonder and awe and appreciation
but there's certainly a segment of nba
fans who don't like him
um there's certainly a segment of nba
fans as we know who don't like lebron
who don't like james harden who don't
like kyrie who don't like kevin durant
i cannot think of anyone else in the
league who's in that you know top group
of guys um who is as beloved universally
and
there is one public opinion on damian
lillard that's it i've now seen another
one well maybe it's because he hasn't
won a championship to piss people off or
multiple championships i'm serious you
know what i mean
i think that's part of it um you know he
is an underdog
he is eternally an underdog right
everybody loves an underdog
and and people love stefan's an underdog
when the warriors were under
this year this year this year they loved
him this year they loved him in 2015.
they didn't like him and that team was
underdogs you didn't like him maybe when
he's cutting down the nets or cutting
you know cutting everybody's season
short you know what i mean like
um or they thought that you know they
were unfairly teaming up with durant
um you know you know i mean like maybe
that has something to do with that
because it can't
be his persona or his way of going about
his business or
you know being a family man and a doting
husband i mean my goodness
so but maybe that's why lillard just
needs to win one to piss some people off
and i'm sure he wouldn't mind doing that
um that's the way i'm looking at it for
the emmy awards too to be very honest
with you
um you know everybody's that's how i
feel about about i mean you by the way i
love the whole self-deprecating act on
your part and i appreciate that and your
humility is actually genuine i've known
you for a very long time
um but there is no reason that you
should not be recognized for the
incredible
work you do and i know you're not going
to give me too much air time to talk
about that no i'll say right back at you
um rachel there's no question about that
as well
and there's and and i just don't know
the way the whole system works i'm just
honored to be mentioned how does that
sound and i think
i think that stuff matters i i i told
you i texted you this when
when the nominations first came out that
for me
to be in that group with you guys
absolutely
means something to me and it means
something to me
prior and no matter what happens on the
night of the awards um
the idea that this group of guys
who i have looked up to um and who
have done it the right way for so long
and done it in a way that provokes
thought and doesn't take the cheap route
um which your ability to have thoughtful
conversation on this show
over and over and over again every day
that is a level of excellence
that i just don't think people realize
how hard it is to achieve and so for me
to just be in that group of people
is legitimately an honor to be nominated
and it's probably not cool to say that
you're supposed to think it's no big
deal and i don't care
i do care because it's awesome if
someone says said my name and the same
sentence is yours and that's pretty
great well you deserve it
um rachel and thank you for saying that
and and if you win
and you see me looking like michaela
moroney it's just my resting emmy's face
okay so it's got nothing to do against
you that connection clearly
is what it's gonna be thanks for the
call rachel have a great show today i'm
sure uh you've got a ton to talk about i
can't wait to see
you indeed thank you check out rachel
nichols the emmy nominated host of the
jump
on espn hey you watched all the way to
the end
thanks for that watch more right here